marriage advice if you don't agree don't
move forward we have always made our
decisions together and if we don't agree
we slow down a lot of times we impose
this false sense of urgency on ourselves
when there's almost nothing that is
urgent if there is no death then a lot
of times taking an extra second to think
okay if we don't agree first question we
always ask is what information are using
often times one of us will have data
that the other person doesn't which is
why if we have the same data because we
have the same values and same Mission we
do ultimately come to the same decision
so often times when we don't agree it's
because one of us knows something or
emphasizing a different piece of
information than the other person and
then we can get down to the information
and talk about that rather than hating
the other person for disagreeing that
has saved me so many mistakes